لكنك تحدت
المتحدث باسم وزارة الخارجية الروسية اليوم ما
حدث ،
نعم بالتأكيد فعلت وأنت تعرف
أحد الأشياء التي تم الحديث عنها
اليوم وكنت في منتدى سانت بطرسبرغ
الاقتصادي حيث من الواضح أن
الروس يقولون إنهم يريدون
إعادة توجيههم  الاقتصاد بعيدًا عن أي
نوع من العلاقات مع الغرب لأنه من
الواضح أن هناك كل هذه العقوبات ،
لكن الأمر يتعلق أيضًا بشحنات الأسلحة
من إدارة بايدن ومن حلفاء الولايات المتحدة والروس الذين
يتهمون الولايات المتحدة بشكل
أساسي بتأجيج الصراع في أوكرانيا
لذلك سألت  المتحدثة باسم
وزارة الخارجية حول بعض
الأشياء التي قالها فلاديمير بوتين
في الواقع أنه يعتقد
أنه في تاريخ بيتر
العظيم والآن يستعيد الأرض بشكل أساسي
يعتقد أنه أه أرض روسية بشكل أساسي
هناك في أوكرانيا و  أدى ذلك إلى
تبادل اختباري رائع ، إليكم ما
حدث
يوم الخميس قال رئيس الاتحاد الروسي  وشبه
العملية العسكرية الخاصة التي قامت بها روسيا
بغزو أوكرانيا بالأشياء التي
فعلها بيتر العظيم في
حرب الشمال الكبرى وقال إن روسيا كانت في
تقديره تستعيد الأراضي
التي كانت بحق روسيا
وتقويتها ليست
اعترافًا بذلك.  خرقًا صارخًا
للقانون الدولي ،
متى ستبدأ في استخدام نفس
نبرة الصوت عندما تسأل سلطاتك
الخاصة لماذا تستخدم نبرة
الصوت هذه عندما
تسألنا ، ألق نظرة على عام 2014 ، لقد أجرينا
استفتاء ، السؤال الكبير
هو العودة و  تعزيز
أقاليم البلدان الأخرى هو أنه ليس
هناك انتهاك للقانون الدولي ،
كان هناك أساس قانوني لغزو العراق ،
فأنت تغزو دولة ذات سيادة ، وقد
ذكرت غزونا
واحتلالنا للأراضي ، ما
هي الأراضي التي تتحدث عنها جيدًا ،
على سبيل المثال المنطقة بأكملها حول
بحر الآزو  أم الغزو يحاول
نحو أه اذهب نحو حيث ظهر الجيش الروسي
في أجزاء كبيرة من
لوهانسك ودون
ربما يكون لديك معلومات أكثر مما
لدي ، ليس لدي هذه المعلومات حول
كييف مناطق
دونيتسك ولوهانسك معترف بها كدول ذات سيادة ،
هناك استفتاءات كما قلت
تعكس إرادة الشعب إذا
قال الرئيس الروسي ما يجري
في  أوكرانيا تستعيد الأرض التي هي في
جوهرها أرض روسية
وتقوي تلك الأرض ، هل يمكنك أن
تشرح لي ما الذي يعنيه ذلك إلى أين
تنتهي ، وأنك تقول إن هذا ليس انتهاكًا
للقانون الدولي ،
فأنا لا أجيب على
سؤالك.  لا تعجبني الطريقة التي أجيب بها ، فأنا
أجيب عليها ربما تتعارض مع
رؤيتك. أمريكا قالت إنها
استثنائية وقلنا أن هذا المفهوم
خاطئ ولكن يمكنني أن أقول لك إن
القوات الأمريكية موجودة الآن في سوريا ولا أحد يطلب
منهم القدوم
لذا كان ذلك  في
غضون ذلك ، تساءل المتحدثة باسم وزارة الخارجية الروسية أندرسون ،
الرئيس السابق لهذا البلد ، ديميتري
ميدفيديف ، على حسابه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
عما إذا كانت أوكرانيا
ستنهي فعلاً  سأكون على خريطة العالم بعد
عامين من الآن حتى ترى
هناك الروس بالتأكيد لا يتراجعون
وأحد الأشياء التي تسمعها باستمرار
من السلطات في موسكو
من الكرملين من
وزارة الخارجية الروسية هو أن روسيا لن تتوقف
عند  ما تفعله في أوكرانيا حتى
تحقق كل أهدافها
بشكل واضح مع كل العواقب على
أوكرانيا وشعبها